all right my first guest is an opinion
journalist for the Washington Post an
author of rise of the warrior cop the
militarization of America's police
forces Radley Balko is back with us from
Nashville Tennessee
thanks for being here Bradley I know
you've written many times about the
police probably more influential E than
anybody in recent years and for a long
time change was slow coming it looks
like that's finally changed and maybe
the straw was broke the camel's back and
now things are changing attitudes are
changing tell me what you think policing
is going to look like in five years
different same somewhat different man I
gotta tell you I mean if you'd asked me
that question two weeks ago I'd give you
a completely different answer and today
I mean we've seen just such remarkable
change in the last couple of weeks I
think I read somewhere there's been a
20% jump among the general public in
questions about things like whether
there's systemic racism police saying
whether police is sort of fundamentally
flawed and needs to be reformed right I
never would have thought for example
that we were in a place where we might
soon be repealing qualified immunity or
there might be sort of you know pan
ideological support this is the shield
that police officers get when they
violate your rights they're held to kind
of a higher standard and this makes it
really difficult to sue them and you
know I never thought it would have been
a popular political position for members
of Congress interest hill to to
dramatically scale back or even abolish
qualified immunity but there seems to be
a growing probably not a consensus at
this point but certainly it's more
popular than it's ever been
you know I think we're gonna see a lot
of experiments Minneapolis you know it's
just sort of gonna tear down into Police
Department and build it again from the
ground up I think we'll probably see a
lot of cities try different things tried
it from lack of interim outsource
different things that we normally have
Camden New Jersey did that did they not
did they not fire the whole to police
department hired many them back but
completely retrained them and it was a
success was it not I think it was done
yeah I think was an unqualified success
they they fired them they acknowledged
the union
and then they rebuilt it from the ground
up where you trained everyone there is
now a union again but it's not the same
type of union that was before and crime
has gone down in Camden since this was
tried and and relations between the
police and the community have improved
immensely so it's been a big success it
does seem like we're often at this
standstill with the police where the
public is saying yeah you know can't you
do it without the brutality the police
are saying we resent that you are
questioning us and the public is saying
we'll then stop doing horrible [ __ ] and
and we don't seem and we don't seem to
understand why you can't have both why
you can't have I think they do it in
other countries where you do have law
and order and police do the job of
police without this sort of we some see
so much sadistic joy from the police and
stuff yeah and I think you know there's
this constant debate over is it a few
bad cops is it is it a significant
number of counts as a majority of cops
and kind of the way I look at it is if
you have cases where you have police
officers who you know are bad who it's
clear I've done bad things whether it's
you know beating people or corruption or
whatever and the system is incapable of
ejecting those people that I think you
you can only conclude that you have a
corrupt system you know it almost
doesn't matter sort of whether it's 1%
of 5% or 25% of cops that are you know
bad if we can't get rid of the bat at
once then the system itself is corrupt
you